[Music]
[Applause]
Eli Manning joining us two-time Super
Bowl champ and of course co-host of the
Manning cast joining us on behalf of
Quaker the official oatmeal sponsor of
the NFL and Eli I'll tell you what he's
doing with Quaker coming up here good to
see you again what's your big takeaway
let's start with the Eagles and the
49ers
yeah thank you Dan uh obviously the
Eagles are playing great football that
pains me to say a little bit but they uh
they're playing great defense and their
offense uh like they've done all year
they just do a good job taking care of
the football and being able to run the
football and and have Jalen hurts doing
these rpos and getting the ball out
quickly he's not taking chances it's
safe safe throws safe completions and so
it's pretty good complimentary team
football that they're able to um you
know to play and they've done it the
last two weeks obviously it's
unfortunate for the 49ers losing they're
they're starting quarterback and they've
you know they've dealt with that twice
already this year it's hard to to lose
your third string Stringer and come back
and then lose your fourth Stringer and
so it's unfortunate they didn't have
kind of all their Firepower in action
and do that but Philadelphia is playing
great football okay as a quarterback
you're looking at who's going to put
pressure on you like Hassan Reddick is
unbelievable now when you go to the
Linus scrimmage how often would you
change your blocking assignments or have
somebody help out because you know where
he is how often would that happen in
your career yeah I mean I think it's
they have to know where their best
rushers are and you know hey sometimes
your your tackle's got to be the guy
that blocks them or sometimes you do
play action where you have a tight end
has to block them sometimes but you
don't want those one-on-one matches uh
matchups all day long you want to try to
keep a a chip by a tight end or keep a
back over there to to chip them and just
slow them down so he's not in a sprinter
stance and firing off the ball uh so I
think it's just that that combination of
having multiple multiple ways to show
different diff you know different looks
at them line up you know line it up guys
over them so you will change things up
um if you know depending on where he is
try to get the offensive line to slide
you know to his side so you can try to
get a double team as much as possible I
know that we love the big plays you know
Mahomes explosive all of that the Eagles
are methodical you you were fortunate
you had a good running game and I wonder
you know what's what's more devastating
to a defense when you get those big
plays explosive plays or we're just
going to keep running the football at
you I think it's when you yeah when you
can run the football at them because
it's it's there's nothing you can do to
stop it and that could be a frustrating
thing when you're loading the box and
you're just getting pushed around and
you're getting moved around and and what
it does also and it slows down the
passwords also those defensive ends are
tired they're playing the run those
defensive tackles are tied they're not
just doing all their spin moves they're
trying to fit gaps and they're worried
about stopping the run and so it opens
up the play action it slows the pass
rush down so you can get you know more
completion so it just when you can run
the football it kind of helps everything
else work better as well and so the egos
are doing it really well and whether
it's you know one of their you know
three running backs they have or Jalen
hurts running it they have a lot of
different ways to keep the ball uh just
got on the ground and not you know
you're not you're not dealing with tip
passes you're not dealing with sacks
you're not dealing with interceptions
and so you take a lot of the back ad
plays out of the game and you can just
control the clock you can shorten the
game and keep their offense on the
sideline for a long time which was just
frustrating as well Mahomes on a bad
ankle I don't know you didn't rely on
your legs but playing with a high ankle
sprain what did you expect out of my
homes
well I thought he I thought he played uh
really really well and made some some
really uh impressive throws moving
around in the pocket and still you know
running up and making off-balance throws
off a bad ankle uh is not it's not easy
and and and he made some some really
spectacular throws I think he did miss a
few kind of some of the easier throws
because of it and just you're a little
bit off and pushing off of and on side
on times and I think sometimes when you
are you're on the run and you're moving
you're not thinking as much and you're
reacting and he made some of those
really good throws but when you're kind
of sitting in the pocket and and things
are a little bit easier you think about
it a little bit more and he just missed
a couple Crossing routes that he
normally does not but you know he he
just competed and obviously the last
play of the game or for the offense when
they uh you know able to run get the
first down get the late hit on the
sideline to put it in field goal
um you know position was obviously a
huge playing the game you know your
longest run from scrimmage
18 18 yards maybe three different times
three different times 18 years electing
numbers yeah there you go and Peyton's
lucky number too
although Peyton's longest was 33.
yeah I saw it it took it took a minute
he's still running yeah yeah he's always
delay of the game do I have a game
during the play
how did you through your career you were
very careful about what you gave the
media you didn't give there was no
bulletin board material but then how
often did you really want to say what
you felt about something or somebody
that's yeah you do that in the
quarterback room afterwards you know you
kind of you gotta like laugh about it
and be able to uh kind of with your
quarterbacks or your quarterback coach
say Hey you know this is what this guy
asked me this is what I really wanted to
say and I couldn't say it so at least
you get it off your chest now you get it
out there and then you know all right I
got I got that done I'm not holding it
in just forever and then one day it's
just all gonna spill out and I'm gonna
have a freak out on the media so I was
always trying to avoid that but I think
you always want to be uh you know kind
of tell the truth and be honest and give
some information but you don't always
have to tell exactly uh what what you're
feeling
give us an idea what the Pro Bowl is
going to be all about with you and you
and Peyton yeah yeah excited a little
flag football uh Pro Bowl this year so a
new uh a new way of playing it and you
know I think the game had gotten you
know a little bad and and there was not
much tackling anyway so we said hey
let's just eliminate the tackling we'll
play flag let's get some of these great
athletes get get them the ball in space
and let them make some phenomenal plays
and you know uh you know Justin
Jefferson and Tyreek Hill like get them
the ball let them let the quarterbacks
throw it we don't need a pass rush and
and let them play a little seven on
seven uh I expect it to be a lot of
scoring uh high high paced uh High
action and so uh I expect the NFC to win
you know Peyton's a uh he's a terrible
coach we all know that a good player bad
coach so I think we're at a major
advantage
uh Tony Dungy said that Peyton would
make a terrible coach because he would
be he he was so but even an analyst he
said he'll drive you crazy
yes I agree he drives me crazy you know
trying to analyze film with him and and
the amount of uh you know voice memos he
he leaves me and and everything going on
so I keep asking for the cliff notes of
the of the memo uh if you could send me
that'd be a lot easier on me and save me
a lot of time but I think I I think with
with Peyton you know he was so good at
seeing the plays and picking the perfect
play and then running it and then and
then and then running it well and
executing it I think if if you know if
from the sideline he wouldn't be able to
do all those things he might be able to
get to some good plays but then if they
don't execute it I think it'd be
frustrating to him I think it'd just be
a very frustrating experience for him
and I think that would come across to
the players and that's what I'm hoping
happens uh this Sunday at the Pro Bowl
as well uh we had Tom Brady on a couple
of months ago and I said you know how
long would it take for you to get your
Super Bowl rings he said it would take
him a couple of minutes
to to find his uh Super Bowl rings well
he has a lot of them though but he does
have a lot how long would it take you to
find your Super Bowl rings uh I mean I
know where they are to go physically get
them and be back and go get them and be
back in this chair and in a minute
a minute last time you won I want to do
it
don't challenge me uh last time I wore I
don't wear I don't wear them much uh
they're so they're so big and clunky
it's like it's not comfortable to wear
and like it hurts your fingers
afterwards I remember but the First with
the first championship we're we're
designing the ring and we kind of talked
about a little bit saying hey wouldn't
it be you know maybe a good idea if we
got a Super Bowl ring and didn't make it
like the biggest thing in the world
where it could actually could wear it
and it wouldn't be like this obnoxious
like bling thing out that like we're
never gonna wear and we're kind of
talking about it and we're designing it
we're going through it and then Michael
Strahan shows up 45 minutes lately we
had it designed like ready to go and
he's like only thing I care about is I
want a 10 table ring and everybody's
like what what's a ten table ring goes
when I walk into a restaurant I want you
to be able to see this thing from 10
tables away all right and we had to
restart the whole the whole deal we got
the big giant why not just a class ring
how about you get a Super Bowl ring and
maybe a like a Class A wearable class
ring it's not a bad idea I think I think
we need to go to the double ring kind of
a wearable one and then you have like
the trophy case one yes uh tell us what
you're doing with Quaker yeah excited to
partner with Quaker and invite fans to
share how they pre-grain before the big
game for a chance to win uh tickets and
to attend the Super Bowl for next year
so uh to enter the contest you can go to
tick tock you can follow Quaker and
between now today and February 12th you
gotta upload your own pre-grained video
of how you're using Quaker Oats to
prepare for the game using uh the
caption hashtag Quaker pre-grain hashtag
entry so upload your video how you're
using Quaker Oats and you got a chance
to go to the Super Bowl next year are
you in a Super Bowl commercial this year
uh no oh what's going on
huh yes is Peyton and is Peyton involved
in one uh there's always a bet like the
over under on Peyton don't have any
Super Bowl commercials he's in I don't
know what the number I don't know what
the official bed is but he is in there
is he in it uh I don't know I'm not I'm
not positive I think we have you know
we've had some kind of through the
playoffs leading up to the you know kind
of leading up to the Super Bowl but
um you know we gotta you gotta you know
you never know you could we got time we
got two weeks I got two weeks I can I
can sneak in one uh good to talk to you
good luck with the campaign there always
good to talk to you thank you always Dan
thanks so much Matt Eli Manning